this kid is the king of excuses every
time I throw him the ball oh that the
lace hit my head dropped it all the sun
got my I at one point I got I said
shut the f up either catch the ball or
say my bed that's it you're allowed two
words my bad or catch the ball and you
saw that's it I'm telling you and it I
mean I trained him like a coach I'm not
like I spend you know maybe a day a week
with him and we spent an hour playing
football and you know the most amazing
thing you're talking about a kid who
plays YouTube video game he's a kid he
goes this is better than any video game
or any YouTube video I loved it I go
that's right kid and I was hard as hell
on the kid I said catch the ball or just
say my bad don't say anything else to be
fair he's not he's actually not
accustomed to that style no at all at
all so that's a shocker when it happens
the first time so kudos to him yeah for
reacting the way he did and not running
crying about it yeah